[Music]
in alternative college news submitted by
trash panda that's a raccoon right oh
that's from guardians of the galaxy -
yeah someone called rocket that oh yeah
who did those you thought I was laughing
it was goodness I remember it's pretty
good I liked it this startup school
offers a one-year alternative to college
for zero money down mmm free alternative
college sounds like you're gonna really
get a job yeah it's like University of
Phoenix should what does that mean
College startup school it's called
mission you let me see their logo sounds
[ __ ] [ __ ] already I didn't
imagine a school with it sounds like a
Mormon University so with this school is
the way it works students don't pay
anything down right as soon as they get
a job that pays at least 50,000 annually
that's when mission you will collect 15%
of that student salary over three years
that sounds awesome actually yeah that's
cool Levon I'm lost in the math weeds
what what is it hmm
I don't understand so if you find a job
that makes 50 50 G's or more or more
that's when they collect 15% so you get
all the education for free so I guess
what they're trying to say is if you get
educated here you will find a job that's
50 G's where your schooling was free
that's good because a lot of those
technical colleges and stuff like
they're I'm still not getting jobs even
though the ads are like Advanced
Placement for whatever you know and
they're all shutting down to get ripped
off and it's so expensive my friend did
like two years what was it the the DeVry
and he tried to go to Community College
and they're like these aren't
transferable credits yeah well that's
cuz he went to DeVry yeah yeah yeah yeah
he's filled with the ITT Tech yeah he's
a bit mad money I went to a trade school
thing for Coleman collar dress exactly
it's another one you you you see on
those infomercials University it's funny
cuz sometimes you see like the
commercials and they're like all
gangster they're like I wasn't doing
nothing with my life with
daytime TV yeah because you know that's
like all the stay-at-home like parents
or like people that are just like down
now and you can hear the wind and the
boom mic yeah yeah I love that [ __ ]
yeah those ones like I have my son and I
had to get my life together that's why
I'm a data entry technician I'll say
what does that mean you work at
McDonald's job yeah would you like
anything else with that
did you know like that's data entry it
was an eleven dollar entry-level job
it's like one step above for minimum
wage yeah you can get a job like that
without spending thousands of dollars
that's very true cuz that's what I found
out about the thing that I did what'd
you do I went for there's a lot of names
for that career but one of them is
central service technician or sterile oh
wait you don't have to be certified for
that well because I thought medical
industry what you went through you have
to get like licenses here's the thing so
with that specific job that I had before
I went in so everyone that was in like
two years before they just got in just
by word of mouth I'm like usually it
would be like the EVs people like the
housekeeping people that they would get
into this career and then you're fine
like you don't have to be educated on
the job training but then they started
changing the rules worthy you need to be
certified in order to do that and that's
when all these private times like these
private schools came out and then I I
think I pay like 12,000 for that this
was on the road to be a nurse or
something it doesn't count towards that
but I guess it's to get your foot into a
hospital and to get paid more than
minimum so I was I got paid really good
well go it's like a surgery thing right
it's like a tool surgery tools tech or
what our instruments are subject yeah
yeah yeah it's like the surgical
instruments I would reprocess them for
them to be used for another surgery okay
you sterilized I'm sure yeah that's yeah
I was called a sterile sterile tech but
yeah so I later found out that I was
like oh man if I would have just came in
a little sooner and if I knew someone I
would have saved myself to a thousand
dollars but
for that same program they're charging
20,000 oh what's the average rate like
entry level rate like when you when you
get that job how much do you get paid
Oh because I remember yet sick-ass
benefits like working at a hospital I
actually never got benefits I was never
a full-time also but if you did get
full-time if I did I would have had
really dope benefit I was getting paid I
think 18 an hour at the time when it was
what was it was probably almost it's
eight years ago yeah I was like yeah
that's that's good for back then yeah I
think how much was a minimum back then
and he's like 7 750 and then it became
like 8 what yeah I don't know what it is
now I got like 11 on 1150 in California
anyways this university here they have a
1% acceptance rate Harvard has 5% but
they're just really selective about who
they get so there were 4,000 700
applicants sounds like you have to have
a bachelor's are ready to even apply or
something some do some people I got
accepted so they out of those four
thousand seven hundred applicants they
only accepted 25 students for the first
he calls it a cohort so for the first
goal it's their first year of the
school's existence okay I mean damn how
did 4,000 people even know about this
well I mean once you find out that
you're going into school getting
education without debt yeah kind of I
mean you are so word travels yeah yeah
and so yeah and this started up in the
Bay Area and they have they work with
companies like Warby Parker lyft
Birchbox Spotify Casper hairy's and Bona
bonobos sama everything [ __ ]
youtubers advertise it's a common I can
everybody yeah and so they work directly
with those companies so then they these
companies get first pick on these
graduates so they can hire them and then
that's when the graduates of start
repaying so then the graduate goes and
works at the [ __ ] blue Krait or
something it actually sounds pretty
legit like they're getting real jobs
from real corporations or
and they actually they get internships
at these companies as well they get like
hands-on experience and then the
majority of this like university is
online so they have these online it's
crazy because what if you land a job
immediately that's like if it's at least
50k right so everyone's paying different
so someone could get like if you're
making one 50k 15% of that every month
versus like someone who just gets fifty
five K or what is that a collage of
satisfied customers no this is one of
their online there's one of their online
classrooms it's like I'm doing an ad for
this right now
sounds like a great deal yeah yeah no it
does so it's like it's like no I know
I'm just like you know I liked it better
when we were sitting on in the beginning
then I feel like I wasted a lot of
[ __ ] time in school yeah schools like
four or six years of like mostly
[ __ ] and you don't even use half of
it anyway so now we're freakin talking
I'd rather do a one-year college yeah
cuz I want one year to guarantee me like
effective [ __ ] [ __ ] that whatever I
learn I'm gonna be able to use this
stuff and I'm just gonna further that I
don't want to [ __ ] learn all this
[ __ ] and then again when I start from a
[ __ ] bottom position you gotta learn
this whole new world everything that you
learn bucket yeah in this article they
have it's one quote from a senior
research fellow at Harvard University's
learning policy institute that's too
long
who said it's great he said more and
more companies are saying what is that
diploma you have it's not a certificate
of mastery it is a certificate of time
served like prison which is what
colleges I I'm not a big big guy I think
look do whatever you want in your life
I am fully supportive that and if that
requires collars and go to college yeah
if it doesn't then your chill but I know
like my friend I have a buddy who who's
like my son is going to college I'm
gonna give him that opportunity and I'll
make your son's [ __ ] eight years
older now and also he doesn't know what
he wants to do yet so let him decide if
he's going to college like yeah
worry about the money it yeah hey man I
have to pay my own student loans you
should pay your own [ __ ] scooter or
class while I had you you can do it you
know family member of mine went to
college and pissed the whole [ __ ]
deal away because he wasn't paying for
it and like because it's free he didn't
give a [ __ ] for granted look if the
grantors had fun you know took a long
time to graduate seven years for a
bachelor oh no people like that
graduated I have a friend that's been in
school for ten years and they still
taking like two classes a semester but
he graduated and then it's like now what
like cuz it's he doesn't have a job yet
you know I'm saying yeah and then he
yeah I think he has a job now in a taco
truck that sounds well he's an
entrepreneur nobody didn't hit him on it
okay now he's working the grill which is
fine but I'm just saying that's not you
know got a college degree and then he's
doing that so it reminds me the time I
gave my brother my car when I was when I
was like 19 I got a truck and then I
gave my brother my car that I had paid
for and I gave it to him oh very nice
yeah I thought well in three months he
blew it up blew it blew it up because
because he never did the oil and he
drove the [ __ ] out of it never did the
oil he doesn't know how to appreciate it
and because it was a gift that he didn't
have to pay for it at all I think he
didn't care and that's how we treat [ __ ]
that that we're giving for yeah yeah so
I think you know if you pay for your own
college you're gonna create a lot better
that's and then you can party and have
fun well you want cuz you're freaking
paying for it I was one of those
financial aid kids I got I think college
is good if your worldview is very small
hey Raul guys I hope you guys enjoy the
video please remember to give us a big
thumbs up and a like like like and also
when you guys sign on YouTube make sure
just kidding news is though first thing
you watch every single day because we
post videos every day okay for more
videos
[Music]